and from 1980 to today i'll give you
exact stats in america okay from 1980 to
today inflation is up 217
just basic inflation so whatever was
worth
you know if you were buying something
for 10 bucks you're paying you know
whatever
20 dollar man ford right 200 what 207
217 inflation from 1980 until today
do you know what the college uh tuition
has gone up from 1980 till today
probably 1999
wow i'm sorry eleven hundred and ninety
nine percent which is exactly like
twelve hundred percent so it's almost
impossible
six times inflation is up two seventeen
college tuition is up twelve hundred
percent
so now why here's why
if if you know how uh
if you start a new business okay and you
got this idea if you go to bfa wells
fargo what are the chances of being b of
a and wells fargo are saying no i'm not
gonna finance it pretty high okay
banks like those types of banks are not
gonna finance your
business idea if you have zero
credibility i'd like a half a million
dollar loan yeah okay whatever this is
not the 60s go somewhere else right so
you have to go get it from angel or you
have to get it from other people right
you're not gonna get it from a bigger
bank
okay
if college education is so worth it
why don't banks finance it
let me say one more time college
education is so worth it because it's
not worth it so so call even banks don't
believe you're going to pay that back so
banks are like saying we're not going to
take that risk but the day the
government said
we will finance college tuition for
every dollar that bank that the
government finances colleges can
increase at 60 cents
so i don't know if that makes sense or
not so every year so you know like you
and i there's a certain regulation you
have when you're competing it's a
monopoly you know you can't compete all
this other stuff so everybody's
targeting companies well they're a
monopoly they're this they're that okay
the ultimate monopoly and everyone's
back you know
corporations don't pay taxes first of
all let me give you one crazy stat
crazy stat on this
there's 13 universities in america that
have
10 billion dollars or more in their bank
account cash they call it endowments
yeah okay harvard number one right
harvard's number one at 53 billion
but you got 10 or 53 billion okay in
savings now let's see who the real
greedy people are watch the statistic
name me a the the you know fast food
place we've gone to the biggest fast
food place in the world what's the name
of it mcdonald's how much do you think
they got in cash
uh so remember the 13th university has
10 billion in endowment it's just a
college okay how much do you think
mcdonald's has in cash
tens of billions 2.3 billion that's it
right
that's it they got 50 000 freaking
locations worldwide employing hundreds
of thousands of people worldwide they're
only sitting on two point three billion
dollars they're the greedy people how
much you think starbucks has in cash
four hundred thousand employees
one how much do you think star wars do
you see where you're going now you're
thinking about it right because these
starbucks only has three billion dollars
in cash check this out facebook trillion
dollar company only has 54 billion
dollars in cash the same as harvard how
the hell does facebook have the same
amount of cash as harvard tesla massive
company only 18 billion okay
disney massive company only 16 billion
in cash how
how so so so and then they have the
audacity to say corporations don't pay
taxes but no one has the audacity to
call call our colleges while they pay
this much taxes march madness zero in
taxes football zero in taxes they get
away with all of that and they get to
charge parents more money every year and
your parents to finance their house and
take money out you're absolutely right i
think i think the phase we are today
people are starting to realize and
question everything people like yourself
people like us were like dude
i don't know what the hell is going on
but i'm questioning and i want to learn
more how the hell does starbucks only
have 3 billion how the hell does
mcdonald's have 2.3 billion in the bank
and we've got 13 universities that have
10 billion or more in the bank see this
the kind of stuff where when you
question it and you kind of open up the
you're like holy [ __ ] they got no
competition and the government's got
their backs and if education is so worth
it why aren't banks financing it maybe
it's no longer worth it yeah and the
worst thing that happened to colleges
and universities you know what's the
worst thing that happened government
getting involved you know what's the
worst thing not the best thing that's
the best thing that happened to them you
know what's the worst thing that
happened to colleges and universities
the internet covet oh okay
best thing happened to us worst thing
that happened in college and
universities you know why
because covet forced people universities
to get cornered covet happens then
harvard students and parents are like
look now that everybody's doing from
zoom and they're no longer on camera
lower tuition yeah you're going to be a
low tuition on harvard no no the stamp
of approval of harvard is you still have
to pay full tuition and then they said
well i thought the experience of college
was
you got a insurance policy because if
something doesn't work out you can
always say i got a degree from this
school i thought it was about the
education i thought it was about the
pride and i thought it was about the
network and the experience of being
there oh
so now i can get a degree online
i don't need to pay this anymore so i
can be a nomad person traveling the
world and still get my four-year degree
hey mom hey dad why don't you finance me
track my grades just allow me to travel
the world while i'm getting my four-year
degree i would much rather do it that
way the worst thing that happened to
colleges was covet and they're going to
pay price for it long-term yeah so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]